Hi, there was a very famous book called
Seven Habits of Successful People and
one of the important habits there was to
start out with the final goal in mind.
Now, your goal is to become a fluent
speaker of whatever language you're
learning, so you have to believe you can
do it. You have to have that vision, the
vision of the enjoyment that you will
have once you can watch movies in your
favorite language, read books, talk to
people, travel to the country. So, every so
often again remind yourself of why
you're learning the language, and that
the goal is to all of a sudden find
yourself as a new person, someone who is
capable, and I've done it on a number of
occasions, you sometimes you think you'll
never get there but you got to keep that
goal fresh in your mind. You're going to
become a fluent speaker of another
language. Keep your goal in mind. Good
luck!